The rehabilitation of the DC Extended Universe
continues with ﻿﻿Birds of Prey (And the
Fantabulous Emancipation of One Harley Quinn)﻿.
The movie has screened for critics, and early
viewers are taking to social media to heap
praise on the Margot Robbie-led film.
This is what they're saying.
Joining Harley in her quest to bring the pain
to Ewan McGregor's Black Mask are a pair of
kickass antiheroes, a Gotham City cop, and
one scrappy kid.
Jurnee Smollett-Bell portrays Black Canary,
while Mary Elizabeth Winstead holds down the
role of Huntress; they are flanked by Rosie
Perez's Detective Renee Montoya and Cassandra
Cain - a youngster who has incurred the Black
Mask's wrath - played by Ella Jay Basco.
Critics near-unanimously opined that this
cast, as they say, freakin' killed it.
Courtney Howard of Fresh Fiction tweeted:
"Delightfully devilish & deliriously wicked,
this irreverent, rule-breaking riot delivers
a contact high.
Cathy Yan is a genius.
Robbie, Smollett, Winstead, Perez & Basco
are perfection."
Some critics disagreed amongst themselves
- not about whether or not the cast aced it,
but rather around the question of who aced
it the hardest.
Angie Han of Mashable tweeted that Winstead's
Huntress is the movie's clear MVP, while FanSided's
Kristen Lopez opined that Smollett-Bell's
Black Canary was, on the contrary, the movie's
real show-stealer.
"What?"
"You are so cool."
Yolanda Machado of The Wrap, meanwhile, refused
to take sides.
She tweeted:
"It's truly an ensemble with every woman bringing
it.
Christina Hodson's script was lively, funny,
& everything I've been waiting for in the
DCEU...Cathy Yan created a Gotham that I can't
wait to revisit."
Chemistry among the cast is great, but Birds
of Prey is a superhero movie, and critics
also agreed that it delivers the action-packed
goods with some of the craziest, most visceral
fight scenes ever put to film.
You heard that right: Yan and company have
apparently created a true action showcase,
the likes of which the DC films had not yet
seen.
Lest you think we're being hyperbolic, here's
what Rosie Knight of IGN has to say.
She wrote:
"Damn [Birds of Prey] delivers!
It's a glittery hard action comedy that has
the best choreographed fight sequences I've
seen in a superhero movie.
It also features my fave comic book film needle
drop ever."
Her colleague Laura Prudom agreed.
She tweeted:
"[Birds of Prey] is a riot - oozing with attitude
and some of the most inventive, bone-crunching
fight sequences in the superhero genre to
date.
I went in with low expectations and was pleasantly
surprised by how much fun I had.
It doesn't reinvent the wheel, but has style
to spare."
Jill Pantozzi of io9 called the fight scenes
"phenomenal," and CinemaBlend's Sean O'Connell
echoed this sentiment, admitting:
"[Birds of Prey] is worth seeing for the kick
ass action and the Funhouse Fight Scene, alone."
The trailers for Birds of Prey gave every
indication that McGregor would give an unhinged,
gleefully scenery-chewing performance as Black
Mask, and we're happy to report that this
indeed appears to be the case.
"For all your noise and bluster, you're just
a silly, little girl with no one around to
protect her."
In fact, we'd go so far as to say that early
reactions indicate that we just might be looking
at the best villainous performances in a DCEU
movie to date.
Griffin Schiller of The Playlist tweeted:
"COULD NOT get enough of McGregor's Black
Mask; hysterical, eccentric, & deliciously
pathetic.
A rockin' kick ass good time!"
ComicBook's Brandon Davis called McGregor's
performance sinister and hilarious, while
veteran film critic Katie Walsh simply tweeted:
"FYC: Ewan McGregor, Best Supporting Actor."
McGregor did have a bit of competition, however,
from Chris Messina - who played the Black
Mask's psychopathic sidekick Victor Zsasz.
Angie Han tweeted:
"Would like to send a lil prayer of thanks
for the costume, makeup, and hair people responsible
for Chris Messina's entire situation here
because wow yes thank you."
Of course, some reviewers jumped online to
point out some of the flick's faults.
Some critics felt that the flick worked better
as a Harley Quinn solo vehicle.
Others had minor issues with the pacing or
the plot.
For instance, Germain Lussier of io9 tweeted:
"Birds of Prey is solid.
The unpredictable structure keeps the first
half moving and the action boosts the rest.
Robbie is excellent, as is McGregor.
It's tamer than expected and the basic story
can get lost in the complex setups but it
works more often than not."
Yes, this is pretty much the closest any critic
came to a negative assessment.
All in all, the flick was heralded as one
of DC's best - thanks in large part to Yan
and Hodson, who have apparently crafted something
pretty special.
The DC Extended Universe may have gotten off
to a rocky start, but it looks like the franchise
has finally hit its stride thanks to more
universally well-received flicks like Aquaman
and Shazam!
Placing an emphasis on solid standalone movies
made by gifted, committed filmmakers has paid
off - go figure - and some critics went so
far as to place Birds at or near the top of
the DCEU pack.
Mike Rougeau of GameSpot tweeted:
"[I'm] happy to report that [Birds of Prey
is] my favorite modern DC movie yet.
Like Shazam!, it carves its own path with
totally unique aesthetic, action, and tone.
Margot, Ewan and all the rest are 100% fantabulous."
Mashable's Alison Foreman called the flick,
quote, "Leagues better than Suicide Squad,"
and opined that this was, quote, "in large
part because we get a rare glimpse into the
rich inner life of a female supervillain (and
it actually delivers on what was promised
in the trailer.)"
Discussing Film's Ben Rolph summed up the
consensus with his tweet.
He wrote:
"[Birds of Prey] is a stylishly fantastic
ride.
Margot Robbie is [in] top form, Harley has
never been quirkier and more lovable.
Well-made, shot with beautiful color and overall,
a sleek piece of grand entertainment.
Also, McGregor is THE BEST.
We need more Birds of Prey, it's great."
Ladies and gentlemen, we have a lot to look
forward to.
Birds of Prey (And the Fantabulous Emancipation
of One Harley Quinn) hits the big screen on
February 7, 2020.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.